even more people are now coming forward
and accusing George Anthony devolder
Santos of stealing money that was meant
for animals in need and it is an
absolutely horrifying situation he made
the claim that he rescued 2400 animals
the counterclaim being made as he
pocketed money he raised in order to
rescue and save those animals it's not
even about a specific lie anymore it's
about the fact that it seems to be lie
after lie after lie after lie good for
Mitt Romney for going up to Santos
during the State of the Union Address
and saying you shouldn't be here I hope
that they keep the pressure on this guy
and force him to resign has no business
being anywhere near any legislative
Authority